one thing we can all enjoy it during
this time thanks to you is your new
album Cortez I mean congratulations
obviously it's um I'm sure you did not
anticipate the album release to be like
this and I know something that you even
struggled you you talked about maybe not
releasing during the pandemic
what made you altima say you know where
I gotta have put the song I gotta show
this such a passion project with my fans
yeah because you know there's moments
where you well I really think that it's
not every time about wind you know
sometimes about sharing - it's really
important so I was concerned because
maybe you know situation wasn't helping
to make a huge a better impact of my new
album you know all the TV shows that got
ponds for cancer you know so I was you
know like the team was like kind of like
what we're gonna do so you know I post
that on my sacrum and my stories or you
guys wanna yeah but you know when most
marry my percentage people being yes
like drop that thing right now that we
need we need pipes we need colores you
know this is a top moment so when I when
I showed out those comments I was like
you know it's true you know it's time to
just give back the love to them and you
know forget about competition and just
like drop the music you know and when
you do things with your heart with heart
they end up being amazingness and that's
how it's been the love has been amazing
about the album and I'm really grateful
that would be read that was it that I
didn't stop it and that the audience
already
[Music]
I wish my fans I get people to follow me
got interesting about me they're never
gonna forget that J Balvin drop a novel
in this moment you know because this
moments are moments that we never want
to forget you know so if I give them a
little light if I give them a little
smile they get up if I give them a
reason to just be happier or just
connect it up reality for a second I
feel they did a great job and I think
that's what we did you did it man you
got me bumping in the kitchen I'll be
cooking up this listen to ya boy like
okay like it's Bob you know you know
thank you you know it's it's it's been a
blessing and I know people are going to
have so much fun when everything is done
they gonna hold these songs
I'm till everything is go back again
you're do not be playing in the house in
the kitchen in the bathroom in the
bedroom you know about when it's time to
go back they good girl but it's gonna
blow up once again you know like another
story it once again so I'm grateful I'm
truly grateful someone else who dropped
some new music during this like strange
and surreal time is your boy back bunny
actually interviewed him right before
all of this went down and yeah you know
he was saying your praises and having
your support have you got a chance to
listen to his album what did you make of
it I love it yeah I love it
he's my you know it's my little brother
you know I know I love him I support him
I enjoy him to his who says success and
and and I want the only crazy you know
like I was the only crazy one before he
got into the game so I'm happy that
there's two local right there you know
like up proposing different things you
know quickly could we talk about a new
music video because he really shook
people I thought it was amazing I mean
I've seen him push the boundaries like
that and drag what was your reaction I
love it like there's nothing that
doesn't impress me on a bad boy
you know impress me in a great way you
know like I'm happy because we need we
need diversity we need you know open
your mind
we need to level up our conscious you
know and and respect and be tolerant
about above sexuality too you know so
it's it's really dull working it was
really needed you know and and I love it
you know there's nothing bad about it
what's great things it's love it's love
well listen I don't think it's too much
of your time but thank you so much Alvin
it's so good to see you now you're happy
and healthy and I can't wait to see you
on the road once we get on the other
side of this thing man Pikachu yes sir
man clothes man the rainbow is gonna be
brighter real soon
[Music]